hey what's up mkbhd here so as you may
have seen barack obama's been on a
pretty massive book tour for his new
book a promised land uh it's been a
pretty great read so far for me but then
youtube reached out
and they're like hey do you want to ask
obama anything about what he talks about
in this book
and so of course i said yes that would
be awesome but that's that's a big
moment for me like what do i ask the
president
if i could ask him anything so anyway
what i have for you are the two
questions that i chose and this is
actually part of a larger uh youtube
originals project called booktube where
he answers a bunch of questions from a
bunch of other creators about that book
and what he wants to talk about
including a really good one from mark
rober about nasa and the origins of the
white house science fair which i thought
were really interesting so i'll link
that below for you to check it out but
this is sort of extended cut of a little
chat and uh i wanted to share enjoy
[Music]
mr president my name is marquez brownlee
i run a youtube channel called mkbhd so
that's mkb which is my initials plus hd
that's high definition that's where i
get to be a huge nerd basically i talk
all kinds of tech products review tech
try to make high quality videos and we
like to have fun with it you know these
days tech is in everything it feels like
it's a part of the fabric of the culture
we live in so on my channel it's
everything from smartphones to 5g
to computers to electric cars basically
anything with an on button all the way
to interviews with people with unique
perspectives on tech it's a lot of fun
i'm 26 years old i've been doing this
for about 10 years now over 10 years so
a long time in my own life
and i also happen to be a professional
ultimate frisbee player so shout out to
the new york empire we had an undefeated
season last year in 2019 and i'm also an
avid golfer and a pretty big nba
basketball fan so i gotta say i'm pretty
excited to be able to talk about your
book a promised land which is your third
book and uh first in a two-part
presidential memoir so i started my
youtube channel in 2009 so a year after
your inauguration which i was at by the
way um i wish i had
some some pictures or something from
that but i didn't have a camera then
believe it or not but i do remember it
was very cold
the timing of this isn't lost on me i
feel like i feel like i owe a lot of my
position
now
to the rise of technology and its
accessibility
and i feel like maybe to an extent you
can say a lot of the same like a lot of
people have called you the first social
media president
but more than that it's just you know
you look at the administration before
you they hadn't quite used it hadn't
quite cracked it then you came along and
all of your teams using social media
embracing technology embracing this new
stuff so can you speak to
that level of embracing technology and
and how it affects our politics and
activating new audiences and speaking to
new people you know obviously we can see
it has its ups and downs but
i feel like a unique challenge of yours
was
finding a balance there that we hadn't
really seen before you
thanks mark has unbelievable hops uh on
that clip of you in uh
ultimate frisbee
you're right technology had a big impact
on my campaign first of all the reason
we were
really early adapters of
a lot of technology as a tool for
reaching out to voters was because
i had a bunch of
folks in their 20s working for me young
people who would come to me and say
listen we had this thing called myspace
and
meetup what it turned out was that
those early iterations of social media
became a really powerful way for us to
build a volunteer base
and a movement
it made me hugely optimistic
about the possibilities of technology as
a as a force for democratization
during the presidency
what we learned was that that same
technology could be used for ill or for
good you know hatred could be
communicated as well as
love and compassion that's something
that i think we still struggle with and
i write about
uh in a promised land how do we harness
this technology for good and try to
mitigate
uh some of the problems that uh that it
creates
so a lot of the worlds that i run in
haven't been
incredibly diverse
right i mentioned golf earlier ultimate
frisbee
technology
and what i can say is at a youth level
and i think at a lot of the beginner
levels
these spaces are more diverse than ever
which is awesome
but you'll notice at a high level
ultimate frisbee not very diverse
at a high level golf
not very diverse and at a high level
technology
still not a very diverse place and i
feel like that makes the spotlight just
a little bit hotter as a black man
moving through these spaces moving
through these worlds i talked about this
a little bit in a video actually i made
on my channel in the past year so from
your book and just from observing
it's clear that you've felt that
spotlight
over time as well i mean not just as the
first black president of course but i
mean just look at politics as a whole
right
so that got me super curious just
how did that make you feel how did that
affect you mentally do you feel like it
pushed you to do better uh do you feel
like it made the way you present things
a little bit different you're extra
careful in the way you articulate
certain things yeah just what's been
your feeling about achievement in less
diverse spaces
you're absolutely right i i write about
the fact that there were occasions where
i would have to deal with expectations
or stereotypes or attitudes that perhaps
if i had been white
i would not have had to deal with
not just me but a lot of the
african-americans or
hispanics
asian americans or in some cases women
were the first in their positions in my
administration all of them had to
navigate spaces where traditionally
there hadn't been a lot of folks who
looked like them
in those situations and it is a
extra burden
uh but
my attitude always was
that it was also a privilege
to be in these environments where you
can actually help
these spaces where you're
one of the firsts and that requires you
speaking out and and having the
confidence that you can uh
that you can propose
solutions that make the whole team or
organization work better